[Música]
com ele hoje é a minha única opção
eu nunca mais ficar de recuperação
tomara que esse ano eu não fiquem muito
mas fico sempre a minha mochila não
tirei um livro e o meu caderno hoje tá
tão vazio de servir como é o nome dos
meus professores mas no final do ano
chegou fui chamado na condenação tuna da
minha mãe lembrou
dava pra ver o boletim na mão foi só
receber caiu a ficha do quanto eu sou
goleiro
fiquei sete eu tô falando sério parei
chorei e não acreditei valeu de novo na
8ª série
caiu a ficha do quanto eu sou lédo
fiquem sete eu tô falando sério parei
chorei e não acreditei olha de novo não
estava certo
[Música]
hoje é minha única opção eu nunca mais
fica de recuperar
tomara que esse ano eu não fiquei muito
mais ricos sempre da minha mochila não
tirei nem eu nem o meu caderno dia vazio
sem nem como é o nome do meu professor
mas no final do ano chegou foi chamado
na coordenação não
o tawa breve boletim na rua
foi só receber caiu a ficha e com teus o
lego
fiquei sete eu tô falando sério parei um
show em e não acreditei
olha de novo na 8ª série caiu a ficha de
que enquanto el soweto
fiquei sete eu tô falando sério eu parei
chorei e não acreditei falhou de novo na
8ª série
[Música]
valeu de novo na 8ª série
a irmã de ponta solene fiquem recente eu
tô falando sério parei
chorei ano
hoje é minha único defensor
[Música]